- There you are, look at you.
- You look beautiful.
You're like glowing.
- (laughing) You are so nuts.
By the way, nothing makes me happier
than watching you sing.
I watch the whole thing
from the beginning.
Nothing makes me happier
than listening to you
say welcome to my show y'all, nothing.
- You and Kathy called it years ago.
You, you called it.
Yeah.
Me having a show.
I was very shocked,
but I'm still getting used
to being back in the studio.
So is it true that you
guys, you've been at 30 Rock
this whole time cause
you're the news, right?
- What was weird I got to
tell you, it was super weird.
I walked into 30 Rock the first
day and I almost like wept.
You've been there a hundred times.
Like the place's magic
comes from its density,
from its people, from Rope, our cameraman,
from Anthony, from our
floor director, Davey,
like that's where you get the
juice and literally to hear
your own footsteps and
to look at the desk,
that's usually teeming with people
and a place that's teeming with life.
You know, usually we have
a million guests wandering
around and you have celebs,
you got an orangutan
that's going to be on someone's
cooking something, you know,
it's just all happening.
And it was just so quiet
and it just, I think
just the intensity of it just struck me.
You sit, you mic up and
then you would just go
and you feel like, and I know everyone
at home felt the same way
who were reporting from home.
You just feel like you're
all by yourself, weirdly.
And the first words out of
your mouth happened to be to a,
you know, a fellow anchor in Miami.
And I think every day, Kel that
it got a little bit better.
Like I remember I thought, well,
I could take a nap on Broadway and no one,
I could sleep there for
hours and no one would,
would drive by.
And I have to say fast
forward to now, man,
I look out our window.
Whenever we saw someone walk
by our window on the world,
like, I didn't care who it was.
I would, I would scream like,
wait, don't go, hold on.
Cause we want to get a shot of somebody,
a person walking by,
a soul.
And it was so empty and literally nurses
would come by Kelly.
They were on their way to their
shift and just stand there
with signs that said that
they miss their kids.
You know, it was, it was
moving, it was emotional.
But I think it was like New
York and a lot of cities
at their finest.
- Yeah.
You're right though, man, the
Today Show, it is always like,
like beautiful chaos.
Like there are so many things happening.
So I can't imagine how that
would have maybe like affected
you, like emotionally, just sitting there
and mentally like your game,
like and how you did your job.
That's weird for it to be so, so bare.